foreign
um so so far we have discussed two
problems or two two kind of uh
formulations one is the worst case
output size by honorable given phone
conjunctive query and the other one is
an algorithm to our chief the runtime
that is predicted by the bound
and now uh let's look at more kind of
practical queries and see why the worst
case optimality is simply insufficient
to capture real queries so here are some
examples
um
so consider the problem of detecting a
four cycle in a graph for example in
this case we have a edge relation and
then we would like to know if there are
four vertices ABCD for which you can go
from A to B B to C C to D and back to a
now if we apply the worst case output
size bound on the on the output of the
query then it's just one right because
it's just uh whether or not uh the you
know the cycle exists so just one if we
apply it on the body of the query which
means you forget about the variable that
we are projecting away then this will be
quadratic because the number of four
Cycles is at most quadratic you can plug
in the IGN Bound and you will get e
squared but from a fantastic paper you
know alone user and zwick release here
um we know that this query can be
answered in time something like e to the
1.5 so obviously our framework so far uh
it's on this end or this end depending
on where you apply it but the actual
answer is is right in the middle so that
means that there's something missing uh
in in most guys optimality framework
now if we you know from the same paper
we know that
um a cycle of length K can be detected
in time something like e to the 2 minus
Epsilon where Epsilon is a function of K
so the longer the cycle is the smaller
the Epsilon will be but it's roughly
something along this line
um and if we apply you know matrix
multiplication type of techniques then
we you know depending on the density of
the graph we can get a different better
exponents
but um our framework doesn't really
capture the matrix multiplication type
of join operator which is yet so we'll
focus on this this type of results
so um another example is let's say you
would like to count the number of K
walks in a graph so what that means is
that we have K plus 1 vertices from X1
to x k plus one and we want to know if
you know how many ways is there to walk
from you know K X1 to x k Plus 1.
now in this case we if we apply the
worst case size bound to the body of the
query then we'll get something like a to
the K over 2 that's a terrible bound uh
you know the longer the walk the higher
this exponent is going to be even though
the output size is only one
and we know
um I'll show you later that we can
answer this query in linear time
essentially it's just K times e
so it is in between but it's closer to
one than to this exponent
s number two
or if we take a conjunctive query with
an inequality like this x you know so
this is a path of length v x y y z z u
and then we require the first and the
last vertices to be different
then in this case again we know that we
can answer in linear time but both of
the bounds are
either too extreme no it's one or two
High
[Music]
so we basically need two new ideas in
the framework so we need to introduce
two two new ideas
so idea number one is that we have to
introduce an abstraction to deal with
aggregation queries because you saw an
example of accounting uh you know number
of paths or something right uh in real
databases you will see you know Min and
Max and summation and existential
quantification and so on and we cannot
come up with a new algorithm for every
new possible application so if there's
an abstraction to abstract away all of
those details so that we can focus on a
generic class of queries that'd be great
so that's ideal we need idea number one
and idea number two is that we need a
better notion of optimality because most
guys optimality does not cut um
cut due to some examples earlier and
here you will see that we are kind of
venturing into fine grain complexity
parameters on Rice complexity and so on
and I hope that this program is going to
help us you know unify or at least we
learn from each other so that we we can
develop together a theory along this
line for these queries for this very
generic classes inquiries
so so idea number one is something that
we we learned and study from the AI
literature
especially in the 80s
and we are going to use a generic class
of queries called the sum product query
and it goes like this so the input is a
collection of functions so just like
before we have a hypograph and for every
hyper Edge there is a function sometimes
called a factor so you think just think
of this as a relation but now a relation
for every Row in the relation there's a
value
your number could be something
so it's just a tiny bit beyond relation
and then the problem instead of you know
existential quantification now we have a
sum so we are marginalizing away some
variables right
so those are variables are called bound
variables and then whatever we didn't
marginalize the weight and those are the
three variables this is some product
query yeah
um so on easy examples in
the conjunctive query case we could have
let's say you know a triangle and then
you marginalize the way a b and c
um oh and by the way uh you know on
Thursday and Wednesday there'll be more
a lot more information about you know
the semi ring and the power that is in
my ring
um brings into the expressive hour of
those queries and so on
um so this is one example uh the Boolean
say my ring you can express the problem
of detecting a triangle uh this way so
the sum becomes or and the product
becomes an end right but this is nothing
but exactly a special case of this query
or if we have let's say a count query
where we want to count the number of
Paths of length 3 for which the two ends
are different
in this case we think of every Edge
relation as a function that marks to
zero or one so if the edge exists then
we matter one if it doesn't exist we map
to zero and so there's some product
becomes a count query here I
intentionally put a group by variable in
front so we are summing away so for
every array we are counting the number
of bcds for which you know you can go
from a uh three steps away so that the
last variable is different from a but
you can vary this you know with
different fee variables with different
bound variables and formulate very
different problems this way so this is
the first attraction and this is uh the
one that hopefully you know by the time
um the AI portion of this Workshop takes
place you'll see a lot more of this so
it's just not
it's not just some of a product but you
could have a circuit some of a product
of a sum of a product and so on and that
turns out to be extremely powerful in
expressing inference problems in in
graphical model for example
okay so that's idea number one
um idea number two is that we really
need a better notion of optimality
because before most guys optimality
which is this right but now as we have
seen the output size could be very very
small right and of course we have to
process the input so there has to be
something in the middle
so now our notion of worst case
optimality or new notion of optimality
will be something like input
plus some parameter you know some
function of the query and worst case
maybe you know satisfying the same thing
plus the output size
um so and and you know if we chose this
function to be this uh then we you know
fall back to that but in some cases this
function could be a lot more refined it
could be anywhere between uh one and um
and that quantity
and uh depending on the query uh
obviously this is functional query
so this is what we are aiming for so it
looks like we've moved to talking about
the output size of the uh query but not
the worst case output size
like the D is now D and not D Prime and
the D Prime is now in the Supreme like
how are those the parentheses going
there right so so D is the is still our
database so the database is fixed right
and we have the statistical profile of
the database this is also fixed so these
are just a degree constraints for
example
but now we are maximizing over all
possible uh databases which have the
same profile
of a function that is a function of D
Prime and Q
um and and so this is this one is still
the fixed database that we are yeah so
so D plus QD is the price that we have
to pay there's no other way around it
but hopefully we can reduce this down
then the red thing that we have on there
okay now this is only good if it's
actually accompanied by kind of an
algorithm to somehow achieve this bomb
and so I'm going to talk about a class
of algorithms uh to achieve this amount
and the algorithm goes like this so the
framework goes like this so we have our
native HD we are supposed to answer this
query queue which is some product query
and then you know this is the output
right
so what we will do is we will kind of
from the database we'll compute an
intermediate representation
so so that from here is actually very
easy to extract the output
and that's kind of a meta query plan
we'll
and this intermediate representation is
essentially you know this quantity
like the time it takes to compute this
is exactly that quantity and hopefully
this will be a lot smaller than that red
quantity yeah
[Music]
I don't know
so then
um uh I guess you could
think about some kind of fine Grant
complexity of ceramic device complexity
of which I'm not qualified
but it is
oh uh yeah so I was planning to say that
we're answering this query
we break it down into two queries we
will come up with qh we'll come up with
QE so e stands for like extraction so
you just extract the output from this
intermediate representation but I wrote
down these notations a while back and
now I don't remember what the subscript
h stand for sorry about that but it's
basically you know break a query into uh
to to have you know the first half is
just to achieve this make it as small as
possible and from here you just get the
answer out easily
right place do you do you do you have to
formally put any restriction in what QE
can do or
like how how do we think about kiwi do
we want something very simple
Properties or
so for for this talk and for all I know
that my QE is
this okay it will be basically somehow
from this intermediate representation we
can run a variable elimination algorithm
to get the output and the runtime of
this will be linear in the input which
is this guy plus the output so it's
basically this term for system or in
other words this term plus system so
that's what QE is I would like to kind
of simplify the query plan as much as
possible so that it will follow this the
script
and so most of the complexity is just to
come up with this
window
and I'll give some examples
there is no other way to evaluate the
query so that it will have a lower worst
case complexity I mean or is it lower
worst case complexity when you follow
this particular plan of decomposition
yeah so the question is uh essentially
is there a way to prove lower bounds of
some sort and whether or not this this
generic query plan is going to achieve
the slow bound that's open right I have
I'm not qualified to you know say
anything about lower bounds really uh
but I will give some examples in which
you know this does seem to achieve some
of the lower bounds that we know for
some queries
I'm from a practical perspective isn't
is it sometimes possible that this
intermediate representation could
actually be more useful to the user than
the entire huge output
makes a lot of sense to try to I mean
come up with good intermediate inter
representations that can do that and
then try to prove like strong results
yeah definitely yeah
so um so one of the very very popular
intermediate representation is the
factorized database that will probably
will tell you more about and from there
you can extract the answer very quickly
but you don't even have to kind of
realize this answer right you can just
compute this representation and keep it
as small as possible so definitely but
um factorization is one way you could
have a circuit to compute this thing and
and that's what the tensor decomposition
part
okay so so now I will you know in order
to explain this this kind of meta query
plan I'm going to explain this part
first the variable elimination part
because this is the easy part where we
get a runtime that is this you know Iron
color
plus the output size
so that's an easy part of this
so variable elimination is can easily be
explained with a couple of examples and
you will kind of get it immediately is a
generic way of doing dynamic programming
and it applies for any same average
so it goes like this so supposedly of
account query where you want to count
our EB SBC and tcd
so in this case uh let's abbreviate
overload notation a little bit I'm going
to use RAB to denote a function not just
a relation that indicates whether or not
a B is in r so this is a kind of an
indicator function same with s and with
t
so
um this variable elimination algorithm
was often cited to Zhang and pool in 94
but I think it was even discovered
before then so I'm not 100 sure probably
someone from the AI literature would
know
is some product but it's easier to do
this
so here accounting becomes uh you know
sum over ABCD of this product right
because this product is one even only if
there is a path from a to d
and if something is the same as
Computing the same product
so all we are doing is to play with the
distributivity of some of the product so
we can push this sum uh in inside
right so once you push a sum inside uh
then here we have a relation tcd and if
we are summing over D then that means we
are counting for every C how many these
are adjacent to the C think of this as a
graph it's just counting a number of
edges you know it's just a degree of the
vertex C right that currently can be
done in linear time
so once you have that then now you have
a a function over uh for every C it will
give the degree of the vertex C
you can store this in a relation
and then we play the same game again but
this time we're pushing the summation
over C inside
right so here now we are summing over
the degree of this vertex C and we have
to check uh whether or not that's vertex
C is in the BC relation right so this
sub query can also be done in linear
time because all we have to do is to
scan over s
for every BC you do a lookup into this
degree of c and just some sum it over
and because we are summing over C
uh so this means that we do this for
every B right for every B just scan over
all of the C's and sum up the degrees of
the C vertices
so that's linear time again and now we
have another intermediate relation V of
B this is no longer a degree this is
like for every B how many two hop you
know these that you can reach from B
so it has kind of a combinatorial
interpretation if you want and then um
and I think this is what a human would
do if you have to actually program this
it would be exactly what a programmer
would do except that is completely
automatic
um now in in the database literature if
you read database textbook you will hear
words like aggregation push down
projection push down predicate push down
that's exactly this
that's just this idea
um apply to different algebra but it's
exactly this this idea
so that's the variable elimination
algorithm
um okay now there's one extra idea that
was basically introduced by Martin
grohay and Daniel Max in uh in 06 in a
beautiful soda paper uh and then we kind
of tried to generalize that to uh to
this some product setting along with a
slightly more General query Plus and it
goes like this so suppose that you apply
this idea on this query
and
um
so if you were to push the summation
over F inside right so typically what
you would do is you factor out
everything that is not dependent on F
right because the more you don't have
inside uh the easier the sub problem
becomes
right so you would Factor everything out
however we um we can introduce the
following idea so if you look at this
there's actually
um
a a function a factor bcde that actually
depends on on E and D right
so it's kind of this this little sub
problem if we didn't have this Factor
then the sub problem will take quadratic
time because you know for one single F
you could have n different E's and N
different D's right so then if you want
to iterate over the answer you will get
you will play a quadratic time for that
yeah
however with this idea what we can do is
there are many pairs e and D that will
never occur in the in the T table right
so it will be a big West to just compute
the over those pairs because they will
not occur uh they will be kind of killed
off by
um by the de entry here so what we do is
we project
um you know this this table back inside
of the sub problem
so this projection just say that well
this will be one if d e is an entry that
will be relevant later on in the
compensation
because if we didn't do this projection
then we would have computed this blue
sub problem for pairs e and these that
may be irrelevant later on and if we are
doing dynamic programming from the
bottom up right so the main problem with
bottom-up dynamic programming is over
computing right uh and this is sort of
like me making the top down part of
dynamic programming by doing the
projection from the outside back into
the sub problem
oh yes so I have to Define that
um so this projection onto the e
of of t
this is a new function
and this is defined to be
one
if there exists
B and C for which T A B's no a b c d e
is non-zero
and there's zero otherwise
um yeah so the whole point of this is
that you know if there were entries that
were zero eventually anyways and we
shouldn't really compute over those
entries because they will be killed by
the multiplication outside
which relations
uh yeah so the question was essentially
in which order of these variables should
we do the elimination
[Music]
but here this idea is just to say the
you know
um
another way to say this is basically in
database is a very important problem is
coordination
and this is exactly that so here we have
a blue query and however we have a later
query in which there's a relation that's
actually de correlation with the support
we just projected back into the sub
query uh to make it smaller
and the worst case size is exactly uh it
went down because now it's just end on
the 1.5
due to this uh you know we kind of
killed off the entries that are not
relevant
um okay so so now that we have that then
we have a new Factor because we are
marginalized away F so now we have a
function or a vector M1
and
um and then we we play the same game
again with some projection from the
outside uh so we have a new Factor M2
and finally here we end up with kind of
a triangle query again and this query we
know that we can evaluate again with uh
West Coast join in and to the 1.5
um so you can see now how was Optimum
actually plays a role in in query
evaluation with
um projections right with variables
eliminated away
and this this home query now can be
answered in time into the uh
[Music]
um
oh so this M1 is just the result of this
it is a function is the relation of two
over three variables actually for every
d and e we have the summation over f
corresponding to that
and
um yeah so
basically the the width of this query is
going to be 115. it's called the
structure
and that
the same idea works for you know csps
that came from the paper by growing in
Knox
now there's another way to express the
same query plan but this this time more
pictorially so if you think about this
sub query there's a blue one and there's
an orange one
um
so then you can represent that with a 3D
composition
already so a tree decommission is a tree
in which every node is a set of
variables so a b c b c d e d e f
and then the query plan uh it says to
you know you gather some of the input
relations or input factors or input
functions uh you multiply them and
marginalize away one of the variables
like f right and the result of that is a
message that is passed to the next node
in a 3D composition
or the parent node and then you compute
the next sub problem and then you know
send the next matches up the root and
eventually the output is computed from
marginalizing away or we see
and and then the right algebra this is
actually called the yanaka case
algorithm or belief propagation
algorithm from Missouri Power in 1992.
so these are basically the same the same
thing
um now both of these papers uh talked
about acyclic queries though so it
wasn't on fraction or hypertrude width
but it's basically is the same idea
okay now for the same query you could
have a different query plan so here uh
back to Pablo's question earlier uh you
know we could have chosen to marginalize
the way
I first for example a different variable
first
so uh it turns out that for this query
that doesn't really matter we'll end up
with Android 1.5 anyways
but the 3D composition looks different
no longer a path in this case is more
like a treat
uh and the width of this decomposition
is still 1.5
okay so now uh let me somewhat formally
Define the notion of 3D composition
um so given a query like this
uh you know there's a lot of
atoms or constraint in the query so one
is r on ABD another one is T on CBD you
could have you know G divided by f is
equal to H and so on so that's that's a
conjunction of constraints right
and the 3D composition is a tree in
which every node is a subset of
variables and this is called the back
no I don't ask me why it's not it's not
about it's a set uh so every node is is
a set of variables
um and uh for which the following two
conditions have to be satisfied the
first one is that if you look at the set
of variables corresponding to one of the
atoms in the body like CBD for example
then there has to be a bug that contains
it so this atom has to contain
be content in one of the bugs
the first condition
and the second edition or you know this
atom g f and H and it's contained in
another background right here right so
that's a containment property
um
and the second property is that if we
single out any variable like B for
example
and you look at all of the bugs for
which B is a part of
then that has to form a sub tree so it
has to be connected inside
those are two main properties
okay and it can be shown that the
variable elimination algorithm is
exactly the same as the message passing
algorithm when you draw the 3D
composition you compose the messages
to send up the tree
okay so so now uh the the question was
uh you know we look at our generic query
plan
and what we do is we decide on the 3D
composition okay let's let's say that
somebody gave us a 3D position which is
the same as the variable ordering
um
so if somebody gave us a 3D position
already then what can we do
well we can run variable elimination
right and you see that the runtime will
be linear in the input plus plus the
output of this portion of the aquarium
now but then the question is how do we
you know compute the minimum
representation here
minimizing this is going to make the the
blue portion of our meta query plan as
more or less as possible
and now we are back to the earlier
question of building the cardinality of
an intermediate relation
so uh what do we have well we have that
for every bug of the 3D composition so
the sky function will map a node of the
3D position to a bar
so
I would think of it this way
you have a 3D musician like this
and T is one of these bugs right and and
this set is kaiti
a set of variables
and our rule is is basically uh we need
to to compute
um
the the satisfying assignments uh for
the variables in in this back of the 3D
news
so just to so that you have this the
right mental picture
that would be uh let's see one of these
guys right
all of the triples d e f in this blue
back okay yeah this this is the chaiti
and and the bound of that will be enter
the 1.5 so so think of the the blue back
as the sky T here which we have to
minimize the size of
okay so now we have the trading position
and we have to uh to compute this query
one for every bag you know one
one query for every work of the trading
position
and so now let's just plug in our
polymetry bar
so we have this query
and
the quantity we are interested in is the
following so first of all we have to
minimize over all possible 3D positions
if you want to minimize this
representation then we better go over
all possible 3D positions right and then
we have to um
for each of such trading position the
worst case will be the worst back of the
the biggest mark
so that's why this is a maxi
maximization maximization you you want
to maximize over all backs of the
trading condition over all databases
satisfying the same degree constraint
of the the size of that output so that's
this what this expression means
so to minimize the middle portion we
have to minimize over 3D position and
then the rest is just the worst case
bound
so uh so then we know this right we have
talked about the polymer tribal so this
will become
uh the main opportunity position and
then Max over Works uh feeling position
and then Max over this polymer bound of
this h of chi T function
so this is the the bound we have been
discussing since the morning
right so so that's our query plan uh is
very very simple
um you know to achieve this right which
is plug in that quantity so this this
blue thing now can be made more concrete
by minimizing over this middle quantity
and if you plug this in so there are
some corollaries for example uh you can
get a fractional hyper tree with bound
of you know from the uh go ahead and Max
paper in o6 and depending on the query
this width could be a lot smaller than
the worst case seismo for example the
width of a tree
which is one so the whole thing is just
linear time and thus the classic
Jordan's result saying that you can do
inference in graphical model for acyclic
models in linear time
um okay so that's uh query plan number
one the other variations
so uh for example if we don't use the
worst case optimal joint algorithm uh we
could use other join operators uh then
you will get some other bounds like the
general hyper with bound you can get a
tree width plus one bound this is a very
common exponent in a graphical model
infants because the effect of their own
dense Factor so you don't get any
advantage from doing the polymer Bond
because it's very very dense just like
dense matrix multiplication
and then later on I'll discuss the sub
modular width which is one notch below
that's one variation
the other variation is that so far I
have only discussed the queries which
has no free variables
you put the three variables in then
there it will put a restriction on the
kinds of three decomposition you
you can use to minimize over
because you have to eliminate the bound
variables before the free variable and
so that limits the 3D position but the
same framework we apply and then you get
something called the FAQ with
okay so that's that's the kind of the
easier part of uh of the meta query plan
and uh finally let's look at another
idea that will kind of put everything
together
uh
so here this is a beautiful idea from
Daniel Max so it goes like this
so so far we have talked about the
representation where we have only one 3D
composition as an intermediate
representation
but Mark says why not choose many treaty
compositions there's no reason for us to
choose as one
so this is now a disjunction over
as many as you want all of them
does that reduce the size of the
intermediate representation somehow
so this is what I would call tensor
decomposition because it's basically you
take a tensor which is just a product a
factorized sensor and then you write it
in a some product form right and then
there's some product form uh this is a
product of uh you know over backs of the
treating position
and we know that for every given 3D
position you can run variable
elimination and you get the answer out
quickly so all we have to do is to run
this variable elimination
many times
but we we know of how to solve this
query from here to here but now the
question is can we actually do something
you know uh interesting with this
representation now
so I'll give an example that we actually
learned from uri's paper let's say you
want to detect four Cycles in a graph
right
detect whether a graph has a four cycle
so
um one thing to do is to run variable
elimination like before so then you will
stick with either this 3D composition or
that 3D condition
you cannot do both
but if you do that then you will get
quadratic time because no matter which
variable you eliminate you have kind of
a cross product like join right and and
the joint if the A3 is a very heavy
degree vertex right then you will join
all of its neighbors with all of its
neighbors so then you get quadratic size
so um so then but now the idea is can we
actually mix this up so we let's use
both of the 3D equalizations yeah
so then what does that mean it means
that from the body of the query we are
now going to uh to find
um
uh tuples to put into either the red
tree decomposition or the blue one
this is an or right so
it's a
disjunctive representation
now but the question is how do we even
compute this thing right because it's
it's not completely obvious how you
would you know iterate over the body of
this query and then somehow you know put
some tuples in in this tree composition
put some of the position the other
training position that might take
quadratic time or even more
how do we solve this problem
well so here's uh one trick
it turns out that in a Boolean case what
you can do is this is exactly equivalent
to this
you can kind of pair up the red and blue
and now you get uh you can write this in
um I guess this is CNF form right so you
go from dnf to cnf1
and the the beauty about the CNF form is
that this is the conjunction
right so then you can solve each of the
sub problems individually so so this
problem for this portion so this from
about this second portion and so on
well that means that we now have four
rules so instead of one single room as
before we have four rows
uh and this rule is is something called
the disjunctive data log rule
it is it has a very very interesting
semantic so I'll explain it in a bit
okay so before when we were talking
about conjunctive query there's only one
one atom or one relation in the head
right then you would existentially
quantify away some variable and then you
put output tuples in there but this is
the disjunction so it's semantic is is
very interesting so let's look at this
semantic
um so the answer to this query this is
called additional query
the answer to this query
contains two tables red table and the
Blue Table
the red table is on three variables A1
A2 A3
the Blue Table is on three variables A1
a2a4
so that the following is satisfied that
if you have a tuple that satisfies the
body so if A1 A2 is in R12 between 3 is
0 to 3 and so on
uh if y1 is enough for one if you have a
tuple that satisfy the body
then the Tuple only has to satisfy
either the red constraint or the blue
constraint
but doesn't have to satisfy both
so you have kind of some flexibility in
constructing the solution because the
solution does only has to cover a part
of the query in some sense
so the way I would typically visualize
this is like this
so in this is in four dimensional but
I'm drawing this on only in three
dimension so suppose that you have a
point like this
then and then you have you know uh
this table and this table so there are
two two tables in the head and the point
is in three dimension and this table is
in two Dimensions so this is B this is C
then in order to record that I have seen
this point you can either put it here
or put it here but you don't have to do
both
so that's the semantic of the addition
data log group
right so I have like a bunch of points
in 3D right it's like this body here
but then I will kind of somehow record
the existence of those points by doing
this you know for this point I will
start this let's say well this point I'm
going to start that shadow and so on and
that is in some way a compression of
of the uh
3D points yeah
so this doesn't uniquely
no it does not uniquely Define the
solution and there are actually a couple
of three different semantics for this
and you can think about kind of a
minimal models Advantage where you
require the solution to um to be minimal
like uh
I'm just giving you the definition of
what it means to be the model but I
didn't give you this the what this means
to be remarked
that's enough
foreign
given a rule like this then
um what is the output size
right so the output size of this row
is going to be well we have two tables
right we have a table on one two three
table and four and the output size I'm
going to Define it to be the maximum uh
over those two tables
it's basically the worst case Shadow
right if you have a bunch of ones in 3D
and you'll take a portion of the Shadow
on one side important on the other side
and take the maximum
so you basically have to balance the
Shadows you cannot cover everything in
just one shot
okay
replacing the decision with t1234 and
then
uh I I guess one way to compute a model
would be to realize all of these points
and then decide which channel to put it
on right to maximize
because you know listing all these
points will be qualification yeah
something the idea is still how somehow
compute their Shadows without actually
computing
the
uh all the points
okay so uh
so now
um
so here is our plan so think of this B
as as the red blue you know one two
three one three four
uh
box in in the head of the rules right so
now we have Rewritten the conjunction
over 3D composition over
um into the CNF form right where we now
can solve each of these rules separately
so this is a disjunctive data log rule
uh much
you know so that that's this guy that's
exactly this guy right here right except
that we are ranging this over a
humongous collection of rules
uh but this is one of those rules right
and then we already have a definition
for the size of a model or this rule
which is this definition right here the
size of the model is maximum over the
one two three t one three four and here
we're just taking this maximum over all
possible colors that occur in the head
right
and now the problem is how do we
you know how do we bound this this
output size how do we even bound it and
then what's the algorithm to compute
this right so we are back again to the
same setting of bounding the output size
of a row except that the rule is no
longer a phone conjunctive query it is
addition data
it's the same the same story as before
and it turns out that you can do
something similar right uh you can bound
the size of addition temperature
using the polymers
just using the entropy argument and the
polymer Bond the only difference is that
there's this extra Min that goes into
another picture
and if you would like an exercise for
your students uh this is an excellent
exercise
so show them the entropic argument for
function conjunctive query and then you
can ask them to to prove this bound it's
very similar but it's certainly
different
that talks about three lines of
arguments so it's a good exercise too
but now that we have the polymatory bone
uh for for this and we can play the same
game and go back and do the Shannon flow
inequality and come up with the you know
user Panda algorithm to solve an acquiry
uh so let me just go for go to the four
cycle example and see how this this
bound Works in in practice Yeah so
remember that one of the additional
rules that we had from the four cycle
example was this one right one two three
one two three four
so uh the boundaries are the the maximum
size of the model
uh in the worst case
um remember this is a little tricky
because this is a maximum over a minimum
you see it has a lot of it has a little
bit of trickiness because the you have
to compute kind of the minimum model and
then you take the maximum over the worst
case so it has a bunch of marks and Men
knowing together
but in any case uh the bounces that
um this is smaller than
the max over the Min of these two uh
entropy you know values so h a one two
three and H A two three four
this is what the polymatory bound says
and once you have the poly motor bound
you can play the same game so the Min of
two quantity is less than the average of
the two quantities
now the average you can now apply you
know sub modularity and monotonicity and
all of that to show that this is this is
just like the Shiro's inequality
actually
however on the left hand side there are
not two things not just one as before
just black Shearer's inequality now you
have this bound and now because this is
less than log and each one of them is
less than log n so you get uh three or
two times block n and this is
essentially why in the ayz algorithm for
four cycle we get the runtime of enter
one
it came from this
so
so then so that's our realization of
idea two right so all we did was that we
replaced this mysterious blue quantity
with a collection of three
decompositions
uh and then we have the worst case you
know bound using the polymer toy bone
uh and well we need a worse guys Ultimo
joining algorithm for a distinctive data
log so this is a little bit more General
than before but we already had the panda
you know the the algorithm is in the
pudding uh framework so we can apply it
the same idea
and
uh and that's what we uh we end up with
the end
um
so the very last thing uh to to mention
uh is that where does the Shannon flow
inequality come from because before it
was just a Max over h of V but now we
have a Max over A Min so that seems to
be a little bit hard to deal with right
now it turns out
that you can show that you know from the
constraints uh you can turn this Min
into a linear combination so it's much
easier to maximize over a linear
combination of things then just maximize
over the minimum
and now you have kind of a linear
objective and you know linear
constraints so then apply focus is Lemma
you'll get the Shannon flow inequality
so that's just one extra technical step
that we have to prove
uh turning this Max I mean maximum into
uh Max linear combination
okay and that's how we get the Shannon
flow inequality uh the only difference
from before is that now this is a linear
combination of edges on the on this
okay so I'm not going through the proof
sequence anymore it's the same thing as
we did before uh
and so one of the corollaries is that we
get like for example the sub modular
width a result from Daniel Max using
this this framework
we for example we could get the ayz
result where you can detect clay cycle
in you know in quadratic you know and
two minus Epsilon time
yeah so the sub modular width is a very
very powerful framework and if you have
General constraint then you turn it into
this format so it will be a little bit
finer than than just D to some power
so I guess back to someone's question
earlier
I guess this is kind of you know
parameterized complexity fine grain
complexity type of result because this
is a function of both the constraints
and the query
does this complexity also hold for
accounting
yeah a great question so
it doesn't quite help for counting
simply because in our query plan
um
and then we go all the way back here
in a genetic query plan now for counting
we have to replace this with a sum in
this with a product right
and in order for the summon product to
be correct they have to be disjoint like
you you cannot over count if it was a
sum overall product and this product
occurs in two different cells that we
are over counting you know the output so
then the 3D conditions have to be
somehow so that you know you have this
dishonest property and uh
um we have a paper together on on this
topic so you could do something like
that but it's not as clean as
side and so that's one and then the the
other issue is that this rule
uh does not apply if you put in here
right so some of these two is not going
to be a product of something like this
simply to overcome
but you could apply this I think maybe
with either important semi rims or this
was
if the summation is unimportant then
something like this might
double counting doesn't
play a role when you know a plus I is
equal to y
EP
in any distributed glasses
so that would be fine
okay so I think that that makes it
basically very high level for uh
for this and
I think I'm done so I'm not going
through the examples anymore because you
can
use the same idea of proof sequence to
join operators and to achieve the same
result
let me just say a few things about the
open problems
so in order to put this into practice
the range of 3D composition we have to
eventually very small because when you
apply the dnf to CNF rewrite when you
you know put distribute the sum over the
product it explodes right it's um the
number of runes that you have to to
answer explode
so the question is can we you know
restrict the number of trading positions
maybe some of them are completely
irrelevant for turning about so reduce
reducing that would be great
the attraction that we built is some
product queries obviously they do not
capture all possible practical parties
right so
it's one class of queries they are
pretty okay for some
um you know aggregation simple
aggregation time queries but in practice
we have many more we could have
um uh you know queries with a topkay
ranking enumeration I guess you know
American Wolfgang and Nicholson will
tell you more about those classes of
queries
you could have queries with arithmetic
circuits so you sum and product and
exponentiation and all of that are very
common in machine learning and those are
much more
difficult inquiries to deal with
um
we need a general theory for tensor
decomposition uh not just the submodular
width but for queries with let's say
inequality or less equality or other
built-in functions I have some examples
of tensor decomposition working for this
but they are not generally enough
yeah so that's uh that's it for now we
are at times
and uh thanks for um supporting too yeah
[Applause]
this one yeah so I'm trying to
understand the theorem what model you
have in mind you told us there are
models and models uh
but
what is the model because at least
there is a stable models which which is
the one that you really want uh it is
exactly some of the design
computations aren't be hard you can very
easily got three vulnerability yeah so
in in our case which we only need one
model and then the same hydrant
reduction of the variable elimination
part is going to eliminate all the
Redundant tools so we only have to
compute one model as long as it's within
this bound and inquiry plan goes through
I see so Computing is
it doesn't help us in the sense
these are not recursive this is not
these are non-recursive queries so um uh
yeah so I don't think stable model I see
so that's right I missed that so these
are just just continuous waves
foreign
play around which model
uh yeah especially if you have recursion
is an absolutely
okay I understand that thank you
so I have my big questions uh so getting
back to so here to enumerate foreign
uses Matrix multiple
implementation of the blindness
not the major exam presentation but it's
a listing so the in terms of your end it
will be n to the if
the difference between a checking and
Counting all the algorithms that check
out
um
yeah so it's a little bit slower
so you will have n to the 1.5 here if we
enter the 1.48
well it gets a
video
yeah I mean
for detection there's passcode
detection yes
pick over problems
more questions
yes what happens if you have projection
s
or human projections
[Music]
yeah so
I think these do have projection so in a
letter of
has an implicit existential
quantification of variables that are not
no I mean the query itself it has
projection
that's the same Frameworks oh yes thank
you
yes
it's the same that we we range over the
3D conversations uh
a certain set of three conditions
capturing this
the pre-valuable and then once you have
those three positions you can do the dnf
you want to see it
is
you can range over the free variables I
mean the treating position for which the
free variables form is sub 3D position
next
more questions
okay this time
[Applause]
thank you